texas governor greg abbott issuing a
disaster declaration amid this
out-of-control border crisis
now the move allows the use of all
available state resources
to assist local law enforcement in
protecting
texans from criminal activity property
damage while the biden administration
is doing nothing to protect texas from
these growing threats just the opposite
they're actually aiding and abetting the
law breaking
but the mob the media they continue to
launch cheap shot after cheap shot at
red state governors
look at this reprehensible lower third
that aired over there at
propaganda msdnc pravda usa
reading quote texas two-step during a
segment about governor abbott
the governor joins us now by the way
also endorsed by president trump for his
upcoming re-election campaign
and by the way governor i second that uh
if if it if it hurts you tell me you
don't want it um
but you've been a great governor the
deal about that sean is we're in a
competition here in the united states
uh where governors are trying to get you
to come to their states
i want you to be attention get out of
here i'm telling you i'm losing i can't
take it anymore in the lone star state
listen i it's really come down to
florida and texas i'm down to those two
uh but i i strongly support your
re-election governor you've done a great
job for the people of texas
and um you i know you'll continue and
listen i i appreciate the
the president's endorsement if you look
at it it was more than just yeah i
endorse greg abbott
look at the words that he used to talk
about why he's endorsing me
and how we partnered up together to do
things like secure the border
to make america greater to create so
many jobs in texas that are now being
crushed
by the biden green new disaster and this
is exactly why
we and why president trump is so
appreciated in texas remember
he was able to get votes in counties
along the border
that other republican presidential
candidates had never been able to get he
won
counties along the border that no
republican
candidate for president had ever won and
it's because
people who live on the border hispanics
who live on the border
they want to have their borders secured
it's contrary to the democrat narrative
where the hispanics on the border they
want open borders that's
false it's not true president trump
proved
that people of all backgrounds who live
on the border who live
inland in texas and america they want a
secure border and that is
what i am trying to step up and achieve
we we
we showed our audience these videos
tonight we've shown our audience
the videos of these kids on top of each
other in biden's cages that he's
building for kids
in the middle of a pandemic um ninety
percent of the heroin in this country
and fentanyl comes across that border
your own child protective services was
denied access
from doing its job you're being
prevented from upholding the law
as the governor of your state because
joe biden and his administration is
aiding and abetting the
the law breaking and making it easier
for the drug traffickers human
traffickers the gangs and everyone else
to do other nefarious things on the
border
and so now we have 34 counties on the
border
who asked me to declare their county a
disaster
which i did normally gubernatorial
disaster declarations are for things
like
hurricanes i don't think this has ever
happened before where a disaster
declaration was made for border counties
because of the influx of people coming
across the border
but i did because we're about to change
the way that
texas addresses the challenges on the
border and we're going to start
by helping these 34 counties respond by
increasing arrests
we've got a new game in town in this in
the state of texas it's going to begin
next week
and then we're going to start why can't
you just say
you're not allowed in and just protect
the border and say go back
i'll be very clear with you sean and
that is you may remember this i know you
did interviews on this
more than a decade ago when you talked
to jan brewer when jan brewer was
governor of arizona
arizona passed laws that did exactly
that where they would send people back
and they would not accept people and the
law that arizona passed
went all the way to the u.s supreme
court in a case called arizona versus
the united states
where the united states supreme court
said arizona does not have that
you know the attorney general that i
used to be and so i follow the law
and the law that i'm going to use will
be legal ways
in which texas is going to start
arresting everybody coming across the
border
not just arresting them but because this
is not going to be aggravated trespass
they're going to be spending
a half a year in jail if not a year in
jail
as well as other actions that i will be
announcing next week
governor i applaud all your efforts i
know you're trying to protect the people
of your state and the united states
you've done a great job in spite of
having handcuffs put on you by the byte
administration
thank you for being with us good luck in
your re-election you've done a great job
for the people of texas sir
thank you sean all right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else